a great result for lanier after a long
tournament lanier you started off very
well but then
couldn't quite get going in the second
half of the tournament but you still
must be proud of this result especially
one particularly brilliant game you
played yeah no definitely
it was a good result of course i was
hoping for more once i got to plus 2
so soon in the tournament
but
but
i mean i was trying in my white games
game against peter and then against sam
i was trying to i knew that
i had to try to
to win one more game at least but uh
well it wasn't for
for a lack of trying so uh yeah today
very solid game
um
yeah and overall i
i think i my
initial goal was just to play good games
uh try to get a good result after
the world cup and i think it went well
how do you assess that trend playing in
a good tournament how does it feel to
play in such a classic tournament a
great tournament like this one and do
well
what does it give you as far as
confidence yeah of course
in terms of confidence it's it's very
very positive so um feels great
i
just looking forward to continue playing
classical chess
as far as the brilliancy prize are there
any games you see that might beat out
your brilliancy
i don't think so oh
immediate
immediate answers i like it
yeah it looks like i'm
the favorite so far
take a look at the magic of television
yeah we have this great moment where
this beautiful movie you play queen to
e1
must have been a proud one is this going
to go in your best games collections for
sure yeah i was thinking it's uh
top three of my best games for sure
all right lobbying hard uh you you might
have a strong chance we can't say
anything yet but you have a strong
chance congratulations on a wonderful
result absolutely brilliant play thank
you our congratulations to you as well
lanier really really marvelous